if you picked up the Indy smash-hit  cuphead on either Xbox one or PC you're  part of a pretty big group I'm Tony and  this is your top-selling GameSpot news  update cuphead developer studio mvhr  announced in a blog post that the  cartoonish run and gun game has sold 2  million copies we don't know the sales  split between the Xbox and PC platforms  but that number has certainly passed the  team's quote wildest dreams for context  the game broke 1 million sales in its  first two weeks after launch at the end  of September it released then on the  aforementioned Xbox one and PC and due  to Microsoft support and publishing it  we won't ever see the game on ps4 it  received a strong 8 out of 10 from  GameSpot and made it onto our top 5 Xbox  one games of the year we've wrapped up  our overall game of the year coverage  too so give that a look for a snapshot  of the best stuff 2017 had to offer  [Music]